but i just thought it was extraordinary
that in 1986 there was council culture
they were arguing about pronouns you
know all the stuff that we see today and
that we you know we tend to we often
blame on mark zuckerberg or jack dorsey
happened in the very first social media
website and to me that just shows you
know what is twitter it's status games
you bring people together you connect
them into communities they start
competing for status
we'll stall look up the show thanks
chris we're good to be here dude i loved
your book it is
awesome
thank you that's really good to hear
thanks chris you nailed it man so you
did all this research about status
throughout all of that what were some of
the weirdest status games that you found
um i i think the one that that i i
always go back to is the yams yeah
yeah in 1948 this anthropologist went to
this tiny island in micronesia
um uh out called pompei and and there um
they had this they had this kind of
thing where
um you know it's very stratified in
pompei life there like it is everywhere
you know but it's quite hard to break
through to the upper levels of pompeii
society but you could do it one way and
that one way is by growing a massive yam
and they would have these feasts these
chiefly feasts and the person who
brought the biggest dam was declared
number one literally that's what they
called him number one and um
and
yeah
and he you know he would there would be
you know raised in status and you know
what happened the inevitable consequence
of that was that the men of pompei just
became obsessed with growing the biggest
yams and they they sneak out their homes
at two in the morning and you know
they'd grow their yams in secret you
know
parts of the forest to cover them with
branches and we could see the yams and
tens of them with fertilizer um and yeah
and you know in human ingenuity and the
human craving for status being what it
is they grew massive yams yam's so big
that it would take 12 men to carry them
into the feces a special stretcher on
poles you know so so that's that's
that's that's status madness it and you
know
as our cat in the book we can direct our
craving for status at anything and we do
and a yam is among those that we can use
yeah yeah what is it is it like a sweet
potato what the [ __ ] a yam
well it's kind of a tuber
but i don't know i don't actually know
what it is one sexy thing
to use for i'd rather get the ferrari if
that's not yes exactly you can't write i
can't ride
down the street
yeah it seems more fun but yeah yeah
assuming you know this is how the status
game works you know
we can use anything as a symbol of
status and it could be a giant yam it
can be
uh yeah a ferrari it can be a lovely
watch it can be um how great an activist
we are you know well the reason that
that example's so funny is that we look
at it and think oh yams how ridiculous
but that objectively there's nothing any
more or less ridiculous of a yam versus
a ferrari or versus being the best
social justice warrior yeah exactly or
you know that you know you know the
classic example is watches you can buy a
casio watch for you know [ __ ] atp on
ebay or you can spend 2.4 million
dollars on on on a watch and it's
they're just telling you the time i mean
and that 2.4 million dollar watch is
just as stupid as a giant yam can't even
eat the ferrari
exactly the ferrari so you say that
status is more important than sex power
or money why is that
well i'm not saying it's more important
i'm saying that you know we have lots of
you know different drives but i think
status is is one of the one of the most
fundamental ones i wouldn't say it's
more fundamental than sex um that that's
really is a basic
but um
you know it goes back to our evolution
you know as i'm sure you know um we're
apes we're a kind of weird kind of ape
that has kind of mastered the art of
cooperative living and so um that's what
we do we we you know that's how we've
solved the darwinian problem of survival
and reproduction we we gather into
coalitions
so we you know we we have this um urge
for connection and to be accepted
and to feel you know belongingness um
you know that's a really important one
but once once we've connected in we
there's always this urge to move up
we're not typically content to be
thought of as likable but useless you
know he's a nice guy but he's just
[ __ ] rubbish you know that's not what
we you know that's that's not human
nature we want to rise we want to we we
want to sort of move up and you know
back in that you know in in in the kind
of hunter-gatherer days when our brains
are doing much of their evolution
it was the case that the more status we
earned um the better food we got the
more food we got the more safe the safer
our sleeping sites the greater our
choices have mate so when you think
about that in terms of survival and
reproduction the more status we have the
better our capacity to survive and
reproduce so that's a very basic idea
that your brain understands completely
go for status because if you go to
status you're going to get that sex
you're going to get that power you're
going to get that yam you're going to
get that ferrari you know the but the
but the basic is is well in connection
first but then once you've connected
once you've connected in with this
coalition of like-minded people
you you try and rise and and when you
kind of take a step back that is human
existence that is human thriving those
groups take the forms of
political coalitions you know businesses
um hobby groups uh cults religions you
know it's that's just what we do as
humans that's that's what that's that's
that that is the basis of human behavior
we gather into groups uh and we connect
into you know we connect into groups and
we strive for status individually in
those groups you know we compete for
status with other people but those
groups then compete with status with
other groups so the status game is
constantly working on those two
dimensions you know internally and right
versus rivals how do you define it
defines state status yeah yeah
it's it's esteem uh being thought of as
valuable um uh useful
um you know it's not just oh you know
connection and belongingness which which
people talk a lot about you know is
about
you know yeah you just feeling loved i
suppose um uh as you might love a family
member or a kind of romantic partner or
you know somebody that you
but but the status is about admiration
um you know respect um yeah you know
feeling feeling somewhat above you know
that's what that's what we like to think
that that's how we like to think of
ourselves and our groups is it like a an
existential currency that our brain sort
of keeps track of
yeah i mean in the book i describe it as
the original currency you know before
that you know we haven't evolved to
crave money
you know money wasn't around when our
brains were doing all that evolution
we've evolved to create status and money
is just one way that we've it's a yam
you know it's the one way that we've um
uh what one way that we that we count
codified status yeah yeah it's another
way that we play the status game you you
can use power as a as a status symbol
and people do but some people aren't
interested in power some people aren't
interested in money money is obviously
very useful beyond its purposes as a
status symbol but but but that's
essentially you know what it is it's a
kind of way of playing the status game
that absolutely directly gets you you
know better resources and
and it enables your uh
survival and reproduction you know it
accelerates your capacity to survive and
reproduce what are the main ways that
people can attain status
so there are lots of sort of basic ways
you know youth beauty age you know but
but both youth and age are ways to get
when you get between 35 and 50
you're [ __ ] and then on the other side
you're all right yeah yeah yeah you know
like like
in the book i think i sort of slightly
could sort of glibly say that but you
know by the hotel pool
youth wins but when you're trying to get
a seat on the train
you know age wins so it depends on the
context um so so yeah you know it's so
traditionally of course age would always
win but now in our kind of youth
obsessed culture um it's it it's less so
but but the the the basic ways that you
know the more interesting ways are the
ways we've evolved so firstly it's
dominance you know dominance is is the
most basic animalistic way that we get
status and dominance is about uh
violence the threat of violence the
threat of punishment
and so that could be you know physical
violence or reputation destruction or
ostracization um so dominance is you
know not you know unfortunately you know
a part of our human nature and has been
since before we were humans uh dominance
is is typically a much more kind of
animalistic way you know
hens peck at each other until their
packing order is established and that's
how they play their status game
um but but we know humans
when we kind of settle down
uh you know we um
developed
um these new ways of playing status
games um you know
some animals do play games with um
reputation too it's thought
interestingly um but but we are kind of
really mastered the art of playing
status games with reputation by earning
prestige
and fundamentally it's about showing
yourself to be useful to your group to
your tribe and there are two ways you
can be useful to your tribe one is our
being virtuous
so courageous generous but also um you
know a good for a conformist good
follower of rules and a good person in a
person who punishes rule breakers you
know that's part of being virtuous um
and the other way is by being successful
being skillful by you know being the
best honey finder the best hunter the
best
grower of yams you know um so so those
are the three kind of essential ways
that we um play status games dominance
virtue and success
and if you think about um those three
different routes to status they kind of
define kind the kinds of status games
that we we play
so you know boxing is a dominance game
it's about violence and it's about it's
about who's the who's the most um
you know dominant individual uh a
religion or a role for a royal family is
a virtue game it's about deference
obedience um following the rules
um and
a corporation or a scientific endeavor
is a success game their audience they're
awarding status on the basis of you um
successfully achieving some you know
closely defined
goal
and just the important thing to to note
here is that there aren't any really
pure games you know all games are kind
of tend to be a mixture of all three
but but but usually one route to status
will be be dominant so
in boxing that's obviously a dominance
game but it still has a virtue element
too because you have to follow these
rules and then obviously it's a success
game you know you're
you have to be it isn't just about
throwing punches woody nilly you've got
to be really skillful to be a successful
boxer so so you can see how all those
three routes to status
are in most games probably all games but
one tends to tends to be it's like a
flavor in a suit the dominant kind of
flavor
which one's most fragile i'm gonna guess
the dominance the fear and
fear and force
um what do you mean by fragile
in that
ruling through fear
to me seems like the least scalable
getting people to actually buy into you
as a human
to get them to want to support you this
person has virtue they are useful to us
we can trust them
that to me seems like it would scale
very well whereas fear and
force inherently seems
more risky
yeah i i think i think there's something
to that definitely and you know when
you're when you're forcing people to
attend to you in status that is you know
in in many contexts an inherently
unstable way of kind of leading a status
game
as you see throughout history um
you know dominant leaders tend to fall
um but um
the research is quite interesting
because it shows that when a status game
a group feels under threat they they
tend to um want a dominant leader to to
lead them uh so so you know
you know
it's a kind of
a typical thing that when when the
status of a group feels under threat
like in terms of war or even a pandemic
um the the people want to be led by
somebody
who who is more dominant and that's
found interestingly across gender that's
men and women tend to prefer dominant
leaders in those times why do you think
that is
well because
we're in trouble you know we need a
leader to come in and tell us what to do
you know
dominance
um
one of the concepts that i write about
in the book in some depth is this
concept of tightness which psychologists
talk about you know groups and cultures
can be tight
tight versus loose and so you know in
the west we're quite we have quite loose
cultures um
uh yeah and you know it's not just in
the west um uh but but yeah you know
uk the us are quite loose cultures we're
not that conformist um uh that you know
we value individual freedom but other
cultures you know germany is a
relatively tight culture the southern
states versus the northern states of
america southern states tend to be
tighter so they're more conformist
there's more dominance going on um
they're better at following rules they
tend to be kind of more superstitious
and and liable to kind of believe
uh you know that the wild stories that
are told uh amongst their amongst their
group and so in times of trouble you
know we tighten up you know even the
loose you know um you see it during the
pandemic in you know especially in the
in the uk
um
uh you know we we we've been very
conformist during the pandemic you know
the anti-vaxx thing isn't isn't a major
thing over here like it is in the states
um we've tightened up and you know you
know my personal default is okay
tell me what to do i don't care just
if you want me to wear a mask i'll wear
a mask if you want me to drop it i'll
drop it just tell me what to do and i
think that's the appropriate that's
actually appropriate in in a in a time
of threat to to to to go into that kind
of tighter
kind of hunker down and and you know
into that kind of tighter more
conformist space how do high and low
status people relate to each other then
well um the the game is always kind of
um jostling you know one of the
interesting things um
the the the you know i read quite a lot
about in my research is this the idea of
you know the copying instinct humans
just are amazing at copying um people
and we tend to copy
the high status people who are in our
game so so they're the people that we
look up to and go i want to be like you
and we'll tend to kind of blindly copy
them and you know it's quite interesting
there was one there was one study that
looked at the behavior of you know young
human children versus chimps and uh the
the the the experiment was there was a
certain procedure
um
that you had to go through in order to
get some sort of treat
and um the chimpanzees you know quite
quickly worked out which parts of the
procedure weren't
you know they were copying they were
learning by copying and the chimps quite
quickly worked out which parts of the
procedure they could drop but the young
humans copied everything they didn't
care they just copied everything and i
thought that was really interesting
because in a sense the chimps are
smarter than us in that in that context
you know they just i don't need to do
that i don't need to do that but but
we're copying everything and that's the
status game and you know i remember you
know when i was eight years old i was
obsessed with
uh this pop star nick kershaw you know
it's completely you know oh my god i was
you know
and i remember seeing him on tv am you
know with his crossing his legs in a
certain way he had his ankle on his knee
and i thought and i just started doing
that you know i didn't know why i was
doing it but i started to go just kind
of sitting around with my ankle that's
going to be my route to become a world
champion pop star yeah and i didn't know
why i was doing it but that's the
programming we look at people that we
want to be like and we you know we i
call it the copy flatter conform kind of
you know uh um the copy flatter conform
process that's what we want to do we
copy them we flatter them oh you're
amazing you know we we lavish them with
status and we conform you know we do
what they tell us to do and that's kind
of a strategy it's because we want to
climb up too and we're looking at them
they're up there so if we copy
everything they're doing um
and we're nice to them so they'll allow
us to be around us then we'll hopefully
rise too
do you think that we actually like
people with high status or do we just
secretly hate them and find them useful
allies
that's a good question because it's a
nuance it's a very nuanced question and
it's something that i really
really kind of wrestled with when i was
writing the book
and so
um the answer is it depends and as i
said i i think you know
generally the the the general fact is we
resent high status people is status is
of such value to us
um and um it's relative so the more
other people have the less we have you
know there isn't just like a you know
score on a scoreboard
it you know if
if i sell this many books but then my
rival sells this many books suddenly now
i'm down here and so we're constantly
constantly measuring other people's
status versus us and you know we've
evolved in in relatively small groups
and you know compared to today's you
know globally connected internet world
we haven't evolved to play these huge
vast games where we're kind of you know
subconsciously comparing ourselves to
bloody michelle obama or the king of
thailand or or whoever it is so so
so you know we are kind of riven with
resentments but there but there are
exceptions to this and and and the
exceptions are really when as i say it's
the nick kershaw thing again it's it's
when we're sort of playing a status game
and we're looking up at somebody and
they're playing the same game as us and
we're like and we're going to that mode
of i want to be like this person you
know i want to learn from this person
and become this person and then you know
that that kind of fights through that
default resentment and
actually we you know we start to admire
them you know we admire artists and
um you know icons who we feel
have a piece of us in them and that we
want to be like presumably there must be
a closeness
um metric that we have in the back of
our brains where you're you and nick
cush or you at eight years old you
weren't competing with him so modeling
his behavior is still a high status
thing for you to do that doesn't look
like deference to a rival as opposed to
if you had
the kid that was in the year above you
and more cooler trainers maybe you and
him could be jostling for similar sorts
of status so i imagine that that that
closeness actually provides more rivalry
as opposed to sort of cooperative
modeling definitely yeah that's that's
absolutely right and and and that was
one one of the sort of more surprising
things that i learned that um
you know you might think that maximizing
the sense of competition between people
would give you maximal performance say
in a company but it's actually not true
you know um too much competition just
get gives you a hellish say corporate
environment you know everyone's
because you know status is freely given
and if status is in short sublime we're
fighting for it no one's going to be
giving out status i mean it's going to
be a miserable
going to be a miserable um you know
place to work environment to be in and
actually um you know but rivalry really
is um
rivalry is something else so so rivalry
happens when as you say when we're very
close
um
feeling very closely competitive with an
individual or a another company and um
it's that closeness that's that creates
the rivalry so so typical rivals have a
history of you know near wins you know
near losses skirmishes and and you know
you can think about apple and microsoft
or you know
obviously apple have now kind of beaten
them in into a pulp uh but but for a
long time happened at microsoft were you
know with deadly rivals because they
were they were close
um you know for for a while
and yeah and i think that works
obviously on the individual level too is
the people closest to us that we become
very rivalrous to and actually rivalry
can be very very motivating you know it
can you know as unpleasant as it feels
it can be an absolute force for success
when when we kind of lock into arrival
and go right it's personal i'm going to
beat you you know
how
what was some of the examples that you
found to do with the ridiculous
relativity
of status wasn't there any was there an
economist article to do with job titles
yeah that's right there were um
it wasn't an economist it was a study i
think it was the 17 000 employees in
britain and and i think by memory it was
70 percent of them said they would opt
for
given the choice they would opt for a
more statusful job title
rather than more money and so um
filing clerks would wanted to be wanted
to be called data storage specialists
was one of them you know and it is funny
but but but they're onto something you
know status is really important
and you know as important as you know
resources are um
you know
status is also extremely important and
and and it's not an irrational i don't
think it's an irrational choice to make
it sounds so irrational though think
about it you're choosing to get what is
essentially just an intangible nothing
yeah over a real explicit objective
quantifiable take it home pay it make it
make it work for you
asset and people would rather have 70 of
people would prefer to get i think i saw
a study as well previously to do with
would you rather
double your workload double your wages
and everybody else stay the same or 10x
your wages and everybody else 20x and
the vast majority of people chose to get
the absolute lower figure but the
relative higher figure yeah that's
absolutely correct yeah yeah yeah that
yeah and and that that shows the
importance of status and you know it
sounds stupid but there are two things
to say about that and first is just to
you know kind of re-up the idea that the
the the
you know we have evolved to crave um
status on a fundamental level you know
psychologically and he is also you know
evident there is evidence also
physically we need to feel like we have
status otherwise we were you know we're
in trouble big trouble psychologically
so so it matters it's like a it's like a
new an essential nutrient for the mind
it status so so we need it and also you
know these job titles it's just an act
of imagination but it's all an act of
imagination the fast car is an accident
you know the active imagination the
flashy watch is an active imagination
even you know our you know our the moral
status games that we play are acts of
shared imagination you know we decided
one day that this is the morally correct
thing to do the next day something else
it doesn't exist in the real world all
these moral arguments we have with
everybody they don't actually exist you
can't find a moral truth under a
microscope you can't dig it out of the
ground you know it's all it's all acts
of imagination you know and that that's
the world that humans exist in we
connect into groups and we have this
shared imaginary games that we play
where we where we say this job is great
and this job isn't great this belief is
great and this
type of activity is worthy of status
this type of activity is not worthy of
status this is something that really
struck me
when you broke down what are consciences
that our conscience is basically an
internal enforcement mechanism for
things that we predict our culture would
reward or punish in terms of status
yeah so it's not my phrase but but but
somebody came i read about it and read
the phrase in sarah jane blakemore's um
book um
and you know she talks about this idea
of the imaginary audience the conscience
is this imaginary audience you know
we're a social animal and you know
status you know if it's not dominance is
given to us you know voluntarily by the
by the by the people that we share our
lives with and so you can you can see
the consciousness this kind of rehearsal
this kind of prediction machine um
um if you if you imagine doing something
really bad you know your conscience
twitches oh you know you should you
shouldn't do that you you respond with
fear um but if you imagine yourself
doing something
fantastic the the the people that you
share your life with are going to think
is great you feel really good and that's
your conscience kind of helping you
predicting and and you know and it also
you know it also obviously works
retrospectively too if you do something
really bad that's the kind of signal
from your from your kind of status game
playing cognition saying don't do that
again you know that is danger danger
lies that way because that because when
you do that it's it's a social thing you
you're dropping in status in the eyes of
your co-players and that is bad you know
that that is in the old you know
it's thought that um capital punishment
was once a human universal so that's the
ultimate cost for you know dropping too
far into status you're dead so
so that's you know that that's the
conscience it's this kind of is helping
us out by predict both predicting and by
you know wagging its finger at us
the things we've done in the past you
know it's like a pain signal i guess in
a way warning you that something's wrong
with your behavior it's interesting that
a lot of the things we value in terms of
morals and virtue they don't look as
selfless in the harsh light of the
status game do they
no i mean i think the initial the
journey that i've been on with this is
is firstly
sorry did you get uncomfortable did you
find it uncomfortable as you slowly
imbibed that a lot of the things that
you valued in yourself the virtuous
qualities you thought you had are just
these shameless plays to desperately try
and get will stores name further up the
endless totem pole of status in the
world
well to be honest i have quite i don't
know i mean i don't know not really i
don't really have a hugely high opinion
of myself i have self-esteem issues i
don't think i didn't go on that journey
i never thought i was this saint anyway
but but but yeah i think you go go on a
journey of of initially quite sinist
quite cynical quite going well you know
all these moral things we do you know
it's a it's a game it's a status game
and you know the pope mother teresa
they're moral superstars you know in the
same way that
you know you know barack obama's a
political superstar and nick herschel
was once a pop superstar you know
they're superstars and we treat them as
superstars when you look at the you know
i grew up in a catholic household when
you look at catholic displays of status
it's absolutely ridiculous you know
you address you know them as your
holiness and they all have these huge
bloody hats on and you know gold
cups you know the the status displays
are so
unhidden
yeah the ostentation so
it's not even disguised in in in that
kind of virtuous world but then after a
while
you know i began to reconcile that and
actually where i ended up with a was a
place not so cynical because once you
understand that the state you know
status is really a fundamental as i say
in human need
and
so so
the mistake is saying oh it's just
status it's only status status is you
know incredibly important to us so it's
not just an only status it's really
important that people feel good about
themselves
and you know secondarily
the fact that our species as has kind of
developed this kind of evolved
technology in which we are rewarded for
doing ver you know out for making
altruistic selfless acts it's absolutely
fantastic that's like probably the best
thing about our species is that we have
you know
both this conscience inside us so we
feel good when we do something selfless
and we're celebrated by the people
around us when we when we act selflessly
is absolutely incredible i mean it's the
best part of us and so so so that's
where i ended up really it it's actually
you know an amazing thing that we have a
system of automatic reward for acts of
selflessness
that's a really cool insight the fact
that
if you were to take the actions
as objectively as you can which is kind
of what philosophers do i suppose right
they remove the presuppositions and the
biases and they look at is doing this
thing actually good in the harsh light
of day it kind of seems like it is but
we've just like imbibed this it's just
this instantiated embodied knowledge
that we just
do
yeah and then you go oh no one needed to
teach me really i just no one actually
ever said all of these different rules
there isn't a huge list of them
somewhere i just kind of know and then
you've got the conscience that acts as
this
internal enforcement mechanism that
makes sure that you you stay on track
yeah it is yeah wonderful
yeah it is i mean and there's some
really interesting work that when they
go around you know globally
looking at you know what are the
fundamental kind of moral rules and and
one of the
of course there are lots of different
ideas about this but the study that i i
talk about in the book is this one that
finds these seven basic
you know
universal moral rules but they they are
very kind of very basic and open to in
you know a huge interpretation it's you
know like respect your elders and or
respect your superiors um be appear
selfless things like this so so
biologically that you know it does seem
it does seem like that there is a there
is a basic kind of very basic kind of
blueprint for human moral behavior but
all the rest of it is cultural and and
you know we learn about it throughout
childhood that's what childhood is all
about it's you know in school with our
parents is teaching us the rules of the
status game of our time and place you do
this good boy good girl bad boy bad girl
it's all status it's all up and down if
you do this you're up if you do that
you're down and you're you know
childhood is about training that
imaginary audience in your head so you
don't need the parents anymore you don't
need the teachers anymore you can you've
actually got it you've absorbed it and
you've become a you know a player of
your time and place childhood is like
training the imaginary audience in your
head i think that's pretty good it's the
first day back to school today for a lot
of kids so they'll be learning whether
or not that internal audience over the
last perhaps two years if not not
actually seeing anyone who's working or
not so what happens if you continually
lose status
really bad things you know what one of
the when i was thinking about you know
in the very very early stages of
thinking about whether even this could
be a book i i kind of set myself a
little task and and that was the task or
question really i you know if you're
going to argue this status is important
it must be really bad when we lose it so
so what does that look like and so i
started to research humiliation the
effects of humiliation and and that's
what really convinced me because
so so the the the definition that i came
across of humiliation is it's it's not
just um somebody taking your status away
from you it is basically robbing you of
any hope of claiming that status again
in the future you're so lacking in
status you're basically banned from the
game
and and you know one psychologist
describes humiliation as the nuclear
bomb of the emotions so when you look at
the very worst things that human beings
engage in from anything from genocide to
honor killings to spring killings um to
you know many instances of serial murder
um it has humiliation at its core
so
so you know
that that really convinced me that
this was a really important subject and
that status was you know a fundamental
human need in the book i tell in some
detail the story of elliot rogers the
in-cell um
and i was able to tell that story
because before he killed a bunch of
people and himself he left a 108 000
word memoir online which was you know
really a truly extraordinary document um
because he uh whilst being unbelievably
narcissistic is also incredibly honest
about his his his shortcomings and his
and his problems
and there you see and and i think you
know what i came to is is the most
dangerous people are not only the ones
who've been humiliated again and again
and again and again but they're the the
but they're the they're the narcissists
the grandiose people who've been
humiliated again and again and again and
again because they feel entitled to a
life up here but what reality is giving
them is down here and down here and down
here you know for years
um
and you know especially if you're male
and you have a propensity to you know
solve status disputes with violence
that's a horrible cocktail male
grandiose and humiliated is really
really dangerous and you know i talk
about you know the example of the una
bomber is quite extraordinary this this
guy
um went to harvard and had
we took part in these basically
humiliation experiments they were like a
government sponsored experiments i think
cia sponsored experiments to see the mk
ultra thing or is that a different guy i
think it was related to that um people
in the comments this is the sort of
thing that youtube excels at so we will
find the answer whoever knows the answer
about mk ultra and the unabomber please
link to a video in the comments yeah so
so you say so they basically got a a a
group of people
including ted kaczynski
and they said you know you're going to
do a scientific experiment they didn't
really tell them what it is is as is you
know normal in psychological experiments
and they basically had them write down
all their or their dp or their or their
dreams and hopes and ambitions lots of
confessions even about things about
thumb sucking and masturbation so all
their all their secrets all their hopes
and dreams and values and then they sat
them down in front of you know these
bright lights and basically mocked them
mocked these individuals and this
happened again and again and again for
years and you know kaczynski's brother
said you know we didn't know what was
going on but we saw the change in him
you know um
and
you know what does the u.n in unibomber
stand for universities why because he
you know they were they were part of his
campaign of terror he would send you
know bombs to universities um
you know he he he ended up with this
kind of mindset
the the the you know all these kind of
scientists who were kind of torturing
him when he was at harvard were
responsible for all the problems in the
world and he was you know the
grandiosity was there he was going to
lead this global revolution and you know
like eliot roger with his 108 000 word
memoir he had his i think 35 000 word
manifesto published in i think it was
the washington post
you know uh so it's obviously a
grandiose man definitely you know
severely humiliated and you see the
consequences
grandiose humiliated and aggressive so
you've got the mail and mail so you've
got the dark triad but this is more like
the dangerous triad that's the three
that you need to make sure that you
don't have yeah it's um
it's interesting thinking about what
happens when people
lose status
that that it gets degraded over time
what about tall poppy syndrome and
people that that sort of have it and
then you have these huge falls because
there's a sense inside
the slow-motion car crash everybody hate
follows some people on their social
media that the ones that you watch just
to sort of pity them because you you
enjoy watching how much they're sort of
wrecking everything and you want to hear
what you mean chris will come on i'll go
through you i'll go through your
following if i need to um but yeah
everyone's got that and the tall poppy
syndrome must be a part of this
yeah totally as i say you know if we
don't directly um you know relate to to
somebody and kind of really admire them
and want to be them we tend to you know
really become quite envious of them and
and so so yeah you know the tall poppy
syndrome has been found to be a
cross-cultural um uh
effect there was a great study that i
didn't put in the status game because it
was in my previous book i didn't want to
didn't want i would love to have cut and
paste into this pollinated
yeah but but it was done by the
psychologists in the university of
shenzhen
and um it was uh
it was really clever so they got these
people and then they you know to say you
know we're gonna you're gonna be taking
part in a neuroscientific experiment but
we're running a bit late and you know so
um why don't you go over there and play
this computer game and and you know just
spend 10 minutes on there
so you go over and you play this
computer game and you go off the
computer game and you say well um you
know just just out of interest you were
kind of pretty mediocre you know all
these people over here did much better
than you and all those people over there
did much worse than you so that you say
okay you sit down and then they put
these people in a brain scanner and they
and they show them i think images or
videos of having injections in their
face and what they were looking for were
um uh signals of empathy because as you
probably know you know when when we
um it's the i think tanya singer i think
that was the neuroscientist that found
this that when we empathize the you know
not the same um
neural patterns but similar neural
patterns will will be seen in the brain
as if we were actually getting that
injection in our face
so they they took them and the people
that they saw were the people from the
waiting room who don't either better or
worse at the game than them and then
afterwards they said to the people you
know um did you feel empathy you know
what did you think about those images
and they said oh it's terrible the
injections oh must have been awful and
they said did you feel empathy for for
them oh yes yes yes did you feel empathy
for all of them oh yes yes yes but the
brain scans gave the lie they tended to
only feel empathy for the people who've
done worse than them that on the game
and they didn't feel any empathy for the
people who did better than them on the
game so that shows you you know it's
just extraordinary evidence for this you
know this tall poppy syndrome that
people who we see as higher status than
us
you know we we don't feel empathy for
them we don't like them
another you know the study that i do
quoted in the status game shows that
peop you know when people reading about
somebody's successful and rich um their
pain signals become more activated uh or
you know the the kind of the the
yeah the pain signals become evident and
and then when when they they read a
story that of that same person being you
know if suffering a fall pleasure
systems become activated so so so you
know it's in us it's the status game
mechanism
in our brain yeah it's it's how we
experience the world and it's not a nice
part of human nature but it but it is an
undeniable part of human nature
trying to map what
you've said so far together it feels
like
we have this sort of
relativistic viewpoint of where our
status works right it's not absolute
it's to do with who we're near
and that
shows of status from people specifically
people that were kind of close to
whether that be geographically that we
can relate to rivals that makes us feel
quite uncomfortable also reading about
it and showing other people having
success that makes us feel less good
losing status is bad for our health it
can cause us to be depressed and it
makes us live for less
shorter amounts of time
does this mean that we should choose our
friends very very carefully
yeah i mean i i would say so you know i
i i mean one of the things i write about
in my my book selfie um which which was
a few years ago now um
is this idea that
it's actually you know
contrary to what all the self-help gurus
will tell you it's very hard to change
yourself
and a much better route to kind of
something that feels like happiness is
by changing your environment changing
you know
yeah i talked about this idea of the the
lizard and the iceberg you know you can
put a lizard on an iceberg and it's a
miserable lizard but take that same
lizard and put it in the desert suddenly
it's a happy lizard and nothing has
changed about that lizard but everything
has changed about that lizard and and i
know i i always think that's an
underrated
you know it's solution for for my
problems is by you know trying to change
our circumstances and as ruthless as it
sounds changing the people who you're
spending your life with
you know it shouldn't be an option that
you just you should just dismiss if
somebody's repeatedly making you feel
bad um then
get rid yeah the bizarre thing is that a
lot of the time we want people that are
motivated that are growth-minded that
make us want to bring out the best of us
but those people are often going to be
rivals they're going to be people that
are doing
well
that have their own hustle maybe it's
not the same hustle as us
and yeah i mean it seems to me that the
best friends for the status game would
be the ones
that are doing worse than you
well it depends on on on how that person
is coming across you know
what we don't like are the people who
are doing well and they brag about it
whether it's a humble brag or it's
showing us or there's constant pictures
on instagram you know or whatever it is
you know it's perfectly possible to be
you know friends with people who are
higher status than you if they if they
don't constantly remind you of that fact
i think it's the constant reminders of
that fact that that kind of that upsets
people um you know it's the humble
bragging and and all that stuff
and also you know
lots of uh yeah it can be really you
know um positive so
i i didn't write the message in the
stages game but in my you know
journalistic life a few years ago i did
a story on crossfit and i went to the
crossfit annual crossfit games in
california and you know crossfit is a
classic example of how
you know these these dynamics can be
used for good people people you know as
crossfit is a status game it's
absolutely a status game it's a success
game um and um it's all positive you
know people people are just there
positively pumping status into you when
you're working out you know and that's
how it works and that's why people get
addicted to it because you know every
week you're getting better and better
and people are clapping you and clapping
you and it's that you know so the status
game can be positive these people aren't
you know that a crossfit group is going
to be bad if it's
if it's in a sense of oh look at look at
you i'm much stronger and faster than
you but that's not what crossfit is it's
all positive so already so that that's
my idea of what what crossfit is it's so
you know it can be you know you can have
healthy status games but but they
they're the ones that aren't
aren't um uh miserly in in the status
you know in the book i talk about how a
successful group is a status generating
machine any successful group is a status
generating machine it's generating
status for all of its players presumably
those status downs state this kind of is
a zero-sum game in order for you to rise
in status you have to rise relative to
someone else that's the whole point so
even if you decide to have your group of
your five friends that you are the
average of and you have that group even
if they do manage to raise you up that
is only in relation to an out group that
you no longer are so if we still got
in-group out-group mechanisms it's just
that we decide how broad we want to have
that viewpoint
it's getting very meta yeah yeah so so
there's two things so so one thing is um
you know the the
status games compete with other status
games you know so so you're competing
both internally and externally and and
and it doesn't have to be i don't know
if it's zero so internally i don't know
that a zero-sum game
um
is exactly right because you know in the
crossfit example you can imagine
everyone's just there will be a
hierarchy there of course there will be
there's anne middleton at the top and
there's me at the bottom you know um
but but if anne middleton's been really
nice to me and going yes mate yes mate
yes mate i'm feeling really good because
that's the high status person making me
feel like i really count and i'm doing a
really good job so that that you know so
it doesn't have to be
you know one of the examples i give as
of a really bad status game is enron the
company enron who had this rank and yank
system so you know regularly the whole
company would be chopped up into pieces
and parts the top fifteen percent would
be rewarded the bottom fifteen percent i
think it was just kicked out and
everybody was you know so everyone's
just [ __ ] terrified and you know and
so you don't wanna be working for enron
you know so so i i'm not
so i think zero some game you know
status is relative but it doesn't have
to be
that doesn't necessarily mean it ends up
being this absolute kind of hellscape
the other thing of course is that status
games compete with other status games
and a major source of status for
everyone in that group is when your game
wins over a rival game you know there
was a really telling
piece by
a quote from laurie lee the author
laurie lee's
autobiography
and you know he he he was you know a kid
at the height i don't know the height of
the british empire but certainly when
the british empire was still the british
empire and you know he talks about being
being about as poor as they get they
lived on boiled cabbage and that was
what they ate and you know but he said
we'd look at the we'd sit in the
classroom we'd look at the map world map
on the walls all the pink bits with the
british empire and he said we'd look at
each other and we'd feel like centurions
you know it's that idea of um
you know when our group when the group
to which we belong is high status no
matter where we are in it we feel great
you know somebody working for apple
computers you can go to the apple store
tomorrow and you can see people who work
for the apple store they think they're
amazing because they work at the apple
store you know
well we need to be very careful about
dissing the people from the apple store
my entire life is built upon that
infrastructure so if they [ __ ] log
into the back end of my icloud and they
break they break everything i'm wrecked
but i have personal experience my first
job when i left school was working in
the local independent record shop and we
were the biggest snobs in the world you
know i was i was working for a shop you
know i was working i think i was earning
85 pounds a week or something and i
thought i was amazing because i worked
at long player and all the idiots worked
at our price and hmv you know i i've
i've i'm saying that about apple because
i've been that person 100
you know the the archetypal indie snob
from high fidelity sneering at celine
dion i was that person when i was 19 so
completely guilty what happens we've
talked about what happens if someone
loses status what about if someone
radically gains status i you might not
know this but i went on love island i
was the first person through the doors
of season one of love island so
correct yes
that is amazing yeah i tend to wait
about 45 minutes before i drop that in
so i've timed it i've timed it about
right
yeah so what happens you you take
vanessa 19 hairdresser from wigan then
you just deposit her in the middle of a
villa and then six weeks later she's got
two million followers and a brand deal
with pretty little thing
what he's still a fan then
no
i've never watched it i've never watched
a single minute i lived it so i've
served my time
four weeks a month or so
i'm gonna watch that scene please don't
please please don't um
see what happens when someone radically
gains status
um i think it's dangerous you know i do
i think you know there's a very
interesting um
uh study that i kind of talked right
about in depth in the book and the the
psychologists it was very small so they
had 12 people which is usually frowned
upon in the world of you know uh
psychological studies but um there were
there were there were 12 unnamed very
high status americans so celebrities um
you know actual kind of celebrities and
and it was quite extraordinary you know
and it was sort of passing you know
their their experience of kind of huge
of huge fame and and they talk about
this process that is initially just
amazing it's just dreamed like people
are calling your name and one of my said
suddenly you matter
um
but then what happens is you know
there are various stages one of which is
that you start losing all your old
friends because
you know
compared to compared to um
uh you they're nothing and and and
and
you can't spend time with them without
reminding him of the fact that you're
now up here and they're down there so
you lose all your old friends the only
people the only friends that you've got
left are the people that are there with
you because of who you are so you stop
trusting everybody and then and then you
know i thought what was really telling
was that ultimately what happens is that
is that they you know some of them
started talking about how um nobody
really knows me and um and actually you
know it was like
they had plenty of the success variety
of status but they started wanting the
virtues kind of variety of status and
they started you know getting crossed
because oh you know i'm actually
uh
you know
the real me if you if you only knew the
real me so so i you know it
it's obviously you know not all it's
cracked up to be fame but but also i
think you know personally i remember a
few years ago meeting somebody who
obviously i won't name
but she um
found enormous success when she was in
her early twenties
um
and um
yeah
in a hollywood film i go that far
and then nothing
and um you know when i met i met her
when she was in her i would say early
middle age and she struck me just as a
deeply unhappy woman you know she kept
referencing the film
uh and the success um and
you know she talks a little bit about
how the fact that she she can't go out
and just get an ordinary job now because
then there'll be stories in newspapers
about look at this person look what
they're doing now um but i kind of you
know i think if you were to ask her
about her success she would probably say
it's the best things ever happened to me
it was amazing but i i left with a
powerful sense that it was actually the
worst thing that ever happened to her
because it ruined the rest of her life
and you know i we we're not designed to
have that much status you know we
evolved in these relatively small groups
um we haven't evolved to have global
fame levels of status it's not good for
us you can see in in the behavior of
people becoming enormously famous um
you know you know you know not not all
the time but especially when they become
famous young you know it does something
to people it turns them into not nice
individuals so so yeah i i i for me the
ideal you know the ideal sort of perfect
life
would be a slow but
you know steady rise in status
throughout your life that that's the
ideal to go for you know you where every
year you you achieve something else and
you achieve the next thing and you
achieve that thing i don't think that's
possible you know um
because there's always going to be
setbacks but but the sudden spike of
fame
when you're 19 20 21 i think is is very
often a disaster because it's
unsustainable
it is like hedonic adaptation
the way that we deal with our status and
then we're so relativistic that as soon
as we've been to that peak now even
though we're continuing to look forward
we've always got this reference point
behind it well i'm not i'm not where i
used to be so yeah i this was something
that i had in my in my head there's a
fitness tracker that i use and it tracks
your um heart rate variability and your
resting heart rate and it gives you a
score and it says this is how rested you
are
and
whether you are green amber or red is
dependent on how you are relative to
your previous period let's say it's a
seven day window or a 14 day window and
if you are better than that then it says
that you are green and if you're about
the same it says that you're amber and
if you're worse than that it says that
you're red
so the only way to get a lot of people
that's a part of this whoop community
they talk about green recovery so seven
green recoveries in a row is like wow
you've nailed your recovery mate but
what they don't realize is that the only
way to perpetually get green recovery is
to sense essentially have a resting
heart rate that drops to nothing and a
heart rate variability which is
limitless because over time
you have to continue progressing
and let's say that you keep your woop on
for 50 years and in 50 years time your
heart beats like
resting heart rate's one a minute
heart rate variability is 3 000 or
something that's the only way that you
could do it and it's kind of the same
with status that the only way to
assuage our feelings of not having the
right amount of status is to continually
grow which obviously i guess
lends itself perfectly to a meritocracy
where you are what you do
a capitalist society where you can
contribute where you want to be sort of
on this wheel of personal growth and
improvement and contribution and stuff
like that
yeah i think that's right so there's a
chapter called the floor and you know
and the floor really i argue it's this
idea is what is exactly what you say is
the fact that we very easily acclimatize
to our sense of status you know we might
suffer wafts of imposter syndrome if we
should get a sudden bump but that
doesn't usually last long and when we
get our rewards we're very good at
deciding actually i deserved all of
those rewards and all my critics idiots
you know that that's what we do you know
we accept the status and we acclimatize
to it and then we want more you know and
we keep wanting more and we keep wanting
more and i think that's why
super famous people end up often not
always obviously but often end up
becoming so monstrous because they keep
wanting more status and more status and
they have to show
um that they um
they they have to show the people around
them that they have more and more status
so their behavior becomes kind of ever
more monstrous so there are some you
know stories in there about kind of
crazy celebrities wanting their i think
was it was kanye west wanted his um it
was they said that the carp in his
dressing was too bumpy and he ordered it
it would be ironed so they had to get
someone to go and iron his carpet you
know and you know somebody you know fred
the shreds the the old boss of the royal
um uh bank of scotland and you know
having it whilst he was making all his
terrible huge sort of cuts um
was having his kitchen in his office
relocated so his scallops could arrive
to his desk um a little warmer yeah so
so you know it makes the you know the
high status can easily make monsters of
us exactly because of that because we
acclimatize to it we accept our level as
appropriate and then we want more and
then we want more and then we want more
what about those inuits that you looked
at didn't they do a song and dance when
people got too big for the boots
yeah that that's when we're talking
about um uh you know the the resentment
again the the fact that we don't like
big shots and
there's lots of evidence in the
anthropological literature of um you
know people dealing with you know what
is sometimes referred to as big shot
behavior and you know i like the idea
that there's one inuit group that sings
a song of derision at people who are the
braggarts and the big dicks you know so
i just thought that was hilarious a song
of derision so they circle the person
that's got a bit too much big dick
energy and they sort of exactly point
and bring him down a couple of pegs it's
twitter essentially but but you went
eskimo twitter yeah yeah
how does the status game relate to
cancel culture
well i mean it's very very very much so
i mean i mean you know
into the internet mobs i think are um
a dominance virtue game it's about
threat it's about um coercion it's about
you will follow the rules of my status
game also virtue signaling on the side
of the of this canceler as well
absolutely yeah
and and and yeah i i think one of the i
think probably the the most interesting
thing the the the idea that really made
sense of cancer culture for me was this
idea called the tyranny of the cousins
um and the the chapter about internet
mobs is called the tyranny of the
cousins and this was a real surprise to
me so so is this the idea that the the
groups in which we evolved very often
not always but very often didn't have
like a big leader big man leader at the
top who was in charge and you know that
was really surprising to me because when
you look at human life today there's
leaders everywhere you know we seem to
love leaders but but they weren't and
and so there was no sort of big single
leader that was in charge of everything
instead there would be sort of a group
of you know elders or kind of high
status
there were relatively egalitarian groups
at relatively high status people that
would gather together to make decisions
at certain times um and you know
according to their specialism you know
different people might have you know
different kinds of sway but it's very
much about um
you know the these early human groups
these pre-modern groups are very much
about consensus or the illusion of
consensus and and so that happens when
people break breaks the rules of the
group you know it wasn't like somebody
would decide you're going to be punished
it was just this sense of consensus
would gather against this person and it
would be an atmosphere of of gossip
people telling nasty stories about him
um and and and that would that would
create moral outrage and more moral
outrage would create more consensus and
it would build up and build up and build
up until you know and in the case in
which i sort of described in the book
this poor bastard um was accused of um
using sorcery to kill somebody and he
was killed and eaten
yeah and
and so that's exactly what you see you
know that is exactly what you see on
social media no one's in charge of a
council culture mob no one can start it
no one can stop it it's something that
that that builds itself up in an
atmosphere of accusation gossip and
consensus and it just and and it kind of
fires at this person and so so you know
the the the tyranny of the cousins is is
about this idea that
you know when we were evolving in those
groups um
we weren't under the kind of fear of the
tyranny of leaders where it was the fear
of the tyranny of these cousins and they
weren't literal cousins but there were
these ideas of these closely
you know the the these these tribal
elders that would sort of
lead and sort of whisper to each other
and and and try and make this consensus
happen and you know it's extraordinary i
could compare kind of a modern mobbing
to a
a deadly mobbing and i think it was the
kabuci tribe in papua new guinea and and
some of the details are
hauntingly um similar in in in what
happens in in these incidents you know
the victims
in a state of panic
when they realize what's happening
you know dancing between conf you know
defending themselves not being too
scared to defend themselves and then
semi-confessing but they're not because
they didn't actually bloody do anything
and you know you see this in the
gaboosie and you see this in you know
victims of cancer culture
you also looked at the first ever social
media network thing
from the internet ages ago and there was
echoes of exactly what we're seeing now
there and it's just a reminder that
perhaps technology has removed the
friction and it's made it more expedited
that we can do this it's quicker and
it's more aggressive and there's more
fragmented groups in groups and out
groups that are playing status games
against each other because of that
frictionlessness but it's nothing new
you know to blame and this was something
that was a tough pill for me to swallow
because i think that human nature i like
to think that human nature is
fundamentally virtuous and good and it's
an easy out to blame the ills that we're
seeing at the moment on
algorithms and and social media but
they may magnify but
the the fundamental of where these
impulses came from
is our nature right yeah absolutely yeah
this was a big lesson i learned again
when i was researching selfie and that
was all about you know
the the kind of the narcissism of social
media and where that came from and one
of the big sort of turning points of
understanding for me and there was the
idea of the selfie camera and you know
the the the the idea was that you know
um
the the the technologist sees steve jobs
fault and it's you know google's fault
for for selfie culture because they put
these cameras on the phones but the you
know the original selfie cameras weren't
called selfie cameras they were called
front-facing cameras and and what apple
and the other companies thought they'd
be good for were business meetings and
for talking to your nan but that's not
what we did with them you know we
started taking pictures of ourselves you
know mostly um so so you know you know
silicon valley are constantly throwing
ideas at us the you know 99.99 of those
ideas get rejected and a tiny mountain
get get picked up and it's the people
it's human beings that decide which
silicon valley technologies are
successful and those and those companies
then you know
tune their platforms and devices around
what we want and you know what i found
in selfies exactly the same as what i
found when i was researching the status
game and social media
it's that you can't blame mark
zuckerberg or jack dorsey for um cancel
culture um
yeah the the first kind of social media
site and as we would recognize it today
was was the well um
which was back in the you know form back
in the 1980s still when people were
having to do that thing with their
phones like off war games i don't know
what it is a modem so it's so it was a
very small group and and when it got to
about
about 500 users so the world was a bit
like reddit so the idea was like um
uh people it was mostly people in you
know in california
they would gather around little interest
groups and they just play little status
games talking about you know wine or the
you know eco stuff or whatever it was
and when it when it got to about um 500
this sort of this individual arrived who
just basically hated men and was just
you know firing off all this anti-male
invective constantly and you know and
and and they kind of mobbed around this
person got them kicked off the platform
eventually deleted as many of their this
person's um
um uh
entries
as possible yeah so so it was all there
and this person was gender
non-conformist so
biologically female didn't identify as
man but used male pronouns and used male
name so slightly complicated but i just
thought it was extraordinary that in
1986
there was council culture they were
arguing about pronouns you know all the
stuff that we see today and that we you
know we tend to we often blame on mark
zuckerberg or jack dorsey happened in
the very first social media website and
to me that just shows you know what is
twitter it's status games you bring
people together you connect them into
communities they start competing for
status and you know with each other and
against you know game versus game and
that's what that and so and you know and
when that started working for twitter of
course they they molded their technology
around these things but they didn't
create it
it was inevitably what was going to
happen you know
yeah quite this is this you know one of
the other things i wrote about and
selfie and also in this book is it's
this kind of utopian technologist idea
the wired you know magazine ideas from
the 90s and the early 2000s the vision
of the internet which is when you
connect everybody together it's going to
be this utopia no hierarchy no
disagreement everybody getting on
together and it's just the opposite of
what happened and it's the opposite of
what happened because it's human nature
you know that's what we do you know for
good and for ill that's what we do
as individuals
is it is it low status behavior to talk
openly
about
status like is acknowledging status
motives a low status signal
yeah that's a really weird one it
obviously is you know people
people don't like to think um
uh of themselves as as only only do this
for status it's a terrible you know we
we readily recognize it in our enemies
but but we we hate recognizing it in
ourselves and you know
and i think you know there's
it's really this idea of the story's
heading brain you know if the
subconscious truth of us is we're just
all out going for connection and status
um as well as other drives you know sex
food you know all that other stuff
enabled by status yeah the the um or
yeah well yeah
yes
and um
the the kind of conscious experience of
life we have isn't that we tell this
heroic story about ourselves
and
you know so so
in several books i've talked about the
idea of the brain as the hero maker it
takes all the messy realities of our
day-to-day life and conjures this heroic
story of self um uh that explains who we
are in the best possible light and you
know and increasingly the way i've come
to see that kind of story is it's almost
like a sales pitch to both to to to the
people with whom you share your life you
know you really believe it's true um
you've got all these biases and
prejudices which which distort reality
you know we even misremember our past in
such a way that makes us feel more
heroic
um so so so i think it's that kind of
sales pitch that story that that is
actually the conscious experience is so
resistant to this idea of status because
it doesn't want to think of ourselves as
that it's a hero maker he wants to say
no i want to change the world i want to
i'm just i'm a good person i am
i am better than everybody else it's not
you know
so um so so yeah i think i think that's
why there's this disconnect you know
it's this it's this
it's this unpleasant subconscious truth
i think in a way did you have a look at
which occupations are the most and the
least anxious around status
i didn't i didn't see any data on that
um i i no i didn't uh anxious
about status no i mean just the most
sort of status anxiety i suppose because
you think about
i mean politics is as far as i can see
almost exclusively
that
like it's all
image and schmooze and connections and
yeah this is one of the things that i
think that that behind the scenes of you
know the west wing or whitehall or
whatever
these people must be just frantic
terrified perpetually constantly playing
this sort of very political
by nature backbitingy status game yeah i
suppose that's why politics is so
fascinating and makes such a great
stories because people's status is so
fragile in the world of politics and you
know again you see you know why politics
is such a vicious
world but simply because status is
incredibly fragile and it can be taken
from you at any moment and there's a
sense of people plotting against you so
yeah i never thought of that but that's
really interesting point yeah i i i
think that's right i mean the one
profession i do write about
in in book is the legal profession
because i found this incredible paper by
this former lawyer and now judge
he wrote this paper basically addressing
young you know young lawyers who just
left
you know law school and were going into
their their big name law firms and he
basically said to them by the way you're
going to pick up within two years you're
going to become corrupt every day you're
going to be making corrupt decisions
you're going to be lying you're going to
be stealing and this is why and the
paper was basically um you know a
description of the status game it was
saying that you know
but by the by the very fact that you're
you're a lawyer you've been to law
school you're an incredibly competitive
person
um
and now you're in a new game and that
game is measured by money and you're
going to become obsessed with money
because every six months the legal
journals print this league table about
who's earning what and you're going to
pour over those league tables but the
problem is you're going to be working as
hard as it's possible to work you know
lawyers are really unhappy people
there's high divorce rate high
alcoholism high drug abuse terrible
working hours so given the fact that
you're incredibly competitive you're
playing a game in which money is your
status symbol and um you're work you're
already working as hard as it's possible
to work what are you going to do to get
ahead well what you're going to do is
you're going to start double billing
you're going to start accidentally
losing documents which are unhelpful to
your uh new client you know and so on
and so on and he said he was perfect
perfectly said it happened to he's going
to happen to you because it and it
happened to me you know so so so you
know i think the league the the the you
know the the ma you know the big name
legal profession i think is just an
insanely intense
status game but by the evidence of that
paper is it possible to exit the state
this game then
no i i it isn't it really isn't um but
but it is possible to play different
games you know and so
one of the sort of really funny studies
that i that i came upon was was this one
that looked at meditation
and you know because we often these kind
of wellness people that say oh no well
you know i used to be really
interested in ego but now i do
mindfulness meditation and so they
studied um 3 700 meditators and these
were meditators were specifically chosen
the ones that were meditating they were
practice was about ego needs and you
know success and status and they found
that they measured very high in in
spiritual superiority you know
and it's just really funny because you
know that's true you know that when
and you know and it would be as true of
me as it's true of anyone if you become
really good at meditating
you start to feel really good about
yourself you start to think ah you know
i've got this insight that nobody else
has got you can't get away from it you
know you can't do it so so um
yeah it's um
i always remember in in in the heretics
um
one of my previous books i i went on a
10 day
silent for passionate retreat really
hardcore meditation
and um
every few hours our meditation would be
interrupted by this british it was in
australia this british guy would come in
all his robes and whatnot and he'd give
us his talk and um
because i i was there i wasn't good at
good at the job of meditating so i bad
my hips were killing me so i'd i was
sitting with my feet facing him and then
on the second day i think it was i was
pulled out and i was you know
of the group and i was bollocked i was
told off because he was so offended
by the side but he said you know showing
me the soles of your feet is very rude i
just thought man you're supposed to be
mr enlightenment right
like you're supposed to be the guru here
and you've just really shamed me and
embarrassed me because you know the side
of my feet was so you know he's just
ridiculous you know it's the whole thing
like it's just ridiculous like it was
comical that he was so chippy about his
status that that that's what he did so
so yeah i mean the only people the other
people apart from meditators who try the
hikimori in japan of course who feel
that they can't connect
they're the shutter waves who who refuse
to leave their bedrooms and when you
look at um
uh you know
the beliefs of the average hikikomori
that you know they they could hear very
closely with what we described as a
status game they say that we are you
know i find it impossible to connect
with other people nobody values me so
they just shut themselves away in their
bedrooms and that's the only feasible
way you can separate yourself from the
status game really in a sense is by
separating yourself from other people
but you've still got that imaginary
audience in your head that's judging you
all the time and probably not judging
shame and guilt yeah exactly so you you
can't but what you can do are play
different games you know if one game
isn't working out for you you know you
can go and play a different game and
also you know
in the end of the book i advise a few
things and one of them is to play a
hierarchy of games you want to play just
one game because because people who play
one games are in a cult and that's the
definition of a cult it's like it's a
status game that's completely exclusive
you're not allowed to get your
connection and status from anywhere else
not your job not your family not your
friends it's us and us alone and and you
know when one group is your sole source
of status you're highly at risk of of
irrational um belief irrational behavior
so cults you know fundamentalist
religious groups ex you know
fundamentalist you know political groups
you know on the left and on the right
you know if these people are sourcing
their connection status from just one
source um they're very liable to start
believing sort of crazy things and
behaving in damaging ways and it's
dangerous to them too because if they're
kicked out of the group or if the group
kind of fails in some way their whole
sense of self fails because they have
nothing in this you know your sense of
self is bound up in the games that
you're playing you are the games that
you play
so so yeah but then the answer isn't to
play lots and lots of games equally
because to to to to re you know status
games are hard and to and and to
actually earn status in the status game
takes
effort and time and um application
so i think the idea is to play a
hierarchy of games really is to have one
main game uh that to which you devote
most of your time but then have you know
a few other ones in this kind of
hierarchy so you've always got that kind
of you've got you've got different
versions of self different versions of
you who are earning status it's got
various different ways and you're kind
of it's like a hedge property portfolio
thing your portfolio yeah so i think
that's the ideal
what are some of the qualities
that people should try to develop if
they want to be a virtuous high status
individual
well i don't know about virtuous you
know one of the one of the things that i
kind of looked at was okay so you know
if there is this thing as the status
game how should we behave you know
what's the optimal
what's the optimal way that we should
behave so i i read the literature on
they call it um optimal presentation i
think or self-presentation you know how
we should
um
um
present to people if we were to be
received well socially and it was very
interesting because when you looked at
what they were saying
it did cohere around this idea of
dominance
virtue and success the three main games
of human life
so so really it's warmth and sincerity
and competence if you if you can if you
can approach people
embodying those three qualities
it's very hard for you to fail in life
because when you when you're warm to
people you're saying to them you're
signaling to them i'm not going to going
to seek status by domination i'm not
going to threaten you i'm not going to
coerce you i'm not going to bully you
you know i'm here in warmth when you're
sincere you're you're you're saying i'm
going to be virtuous you know i'm not
going to [ __ ] you um you know when
things are going badly i'm going to tell
you they're going badly because you know
the whole point of prestige the success
of virtue is you're useful so i'm going
to be useful because i'm going to be
sincere i'm going to tell you the truth
you know in a warm way and then finally
a competence you know um i'm going to be
useful i've got all the i've got this
skill um and you know you're going to
learn this skill too and together and
this skill is useful for our game and
it's going to help help our game win in
its um competition with rival games so
so i think that's the really you know i
call it a blessed triangle of qualities
warm sincerity and competence if you can
embody those three qualities
it's hard for you to fail in life
i love it will store ladies and
gentlemen the status game on social
position and how we use it is this the
cover of the main one so this is a joke
so this is a galley copy and i don't
know if anyone's ever gonna are you all
right for me to show this can i show
what this looks like yeah so yeah um
this is there we go we're in focus this
is
the smartest galley cover
i have ever seen so for the people that
are just listening it says to state this
game on social position and how we use
it and that takes up about ten percent
of the front and then in huge letters
below it says buy the best-selling
author will store
it's huge that takes up all of the
bottom of it
dude i i wondered i was talking to a
friend i was like if he decides to do it
it's really ballsy because presumably it
probably doesn't convert well
when it's on the airport
um whatever bookshelf but i was like
that is
[ __ ] brilliant so i'm glad that i'm
i'm happy that i got this one if people
saw the designer's options and that was
at the bottom i think that they'd done
that as a joke but i was like that is
amazing that we've got i'm campaigning
for that to be the paperback cover but
i'm not sure i have had some feedback
from people who haven't got it and they
just think oh i'm being a dick so
you know how big the text is that
they've got your name on on here i think
it's really funny people that don't get
irony if anyone wants to keep up to date
with what you're doing where should they
go um twitter's the best place at w
store s-t-o-r amazing well thank you bro
cheers chris it was great talking to you
thank you thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe makes me very
happy indeed
peace